MORE ON THIS HISTORIC REVERSAL.
STEPHANIE, WHAT DO YOU KNOW?
>> YEAH, THIS IS DEFINITELY
HISTORIC, VICTOR AND ALISON.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY'S HISTORY THAT
THEY'RE RETURNING PROPERTY THAT
WAS SNATCHED AND RETURNING IT TO
THEIR HEIRS.
THIS WAS PROPERTY THAT CHARLES
AND WILLA BRUCE BOUGHT IN 1912
FOR $1,225 FOR A PARCEL OF LAND,
AND THEN THEY ENDED UP GETTING
ANOTHER PARCEL THEY BOUGHT RIGHT
NEXT TO IT.
THOSE TWO PIECES OF PROPERTY
THAT HAD WERE RIGHT ON FRONT, IN
FRONT OF THE OCEAN, AND THEY
BUILT A BUSINESS THERE CALLED
BRUCE'S BEACH WHERE THEY WERE
ABLE TO INVITE BLACK PEOPLE FROM
ALL OVER TO COME AND ENJOY THE
BEACH.
BLACK PEOPLE COULDN'T GO
EVERYWHERE IN THE '20s TO ENJOY
THE BEACH, IN THE EARLY PART OF
THE 1900s AS WELL.
THIS WAS A THRIVING BUSINESS
THEY HAD, BUT THERE WERE SOME
WHITE PEOPLE AROUND WHO DID NOT
LIKE THAT THIS BUSINESS EXISTED
AND THAT THEY WERE DOING SO
WELL.
SO IN 1924, THE CITY OF
MANHATTAN BEACH SEIZED THE
PROPERTY UNDER EMINENT DOMAIN,
AND JUST THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT
DID TO THE GENERATIONAL WEALTH
THAT WAS OBLITERATED FROM THE
BRUCE FAMILY.
TAKE A LISTEN TO CHIEF DWAYNE
YELLOWFEATHER SHEPHERD WHO IS A
FAMILY MEMBER, A COUSIN OF THE
DIRECT HEIRS AND ALSO A FAMILY
SPOKESPERSON TALK TO THAT EXACT
POINT.
>> AND SO FIRST OF ALL, THE LOSS
OF THE GENERATIONAL WEALTH THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN ACCUMULATED OVER
THE COURSE OF 98 YEARS NOW.
AND JUST THE IDEA OF ALL OF THE
TERROR THAT IS STILL IN OUR
HEARTS REGARDING THESE CRIMINAL
ACTS THAT WERE PERPETRATED
AGAINST INNOCENT PEOPLE OF OUR
FAMILY.
YOU KNOW, IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
FOR PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND AS
WELL, MORE SO THAN THE MONEY
THAT WAS LOST, IT'S OUR HEARTS
THAT WERE LOST.
WE LOST OUR FAMILY TO THIS.
CHARLES AND WILLA BRUCE DIED
ESSENTIALLY FIVE YEARS LATER,
FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS LATER, AFTER
ALL OF THIS HAPPENED.
>> NOW, THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY YESTERDAY TO RETURN
THE PROPERTY TO THE BRUCE
FAMILY.
THE GREAT, GREAT GRANDCHILDREN
OF CHARLES AND WILLA BRUCE.
AND FOR THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE,
THE COUNTY WILL LEASE BACK THE
PROPERTY BECAUSE THERE'S A
LIFEGUARD TRAINING FACILITY
THERE ON THE PROPERTY FOR NOW,
THEY'LL LEASE IT BACK FOR
$413,000 A YEAR.
BUT THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT
YOU HAVE SEEN SOMETHING LIKE
THIS WHERE THE PROPERTY IS GOING
BACK TO THE